un emplacement idéal la rue porte le nom
de la pucelle d'orléans tout a été pensé
pour faire de cette vitrine una
tradition ne restait plus que le maître
de cérémonie
vinaigre de vin blanc élaboré en fût de
chêne
échalotes de bretagne et une pointe de
jus de framboise claude olivier claude
pierre a longtemps travaillé à
l'international dans l'agroalimentaire
puis avec son associé ils ont jeté leur
dévolu sur une belle endormie la maison
martin pourrait 10 797 pour la sortir de
sa léthargie nous avons choisi ce
magasin parce que dans les choses à voir
sur orléans n'a vu sur internet qui
avait notamment la maison pour elle et
le villa dernier vinaigrier d'orléans
vie à visiter le concept de bar à
vinaigre dit-il palais et fait mouche le
vinaigre de vin ou chine où vont mes
treize mois à le fabriquer voilà madame
est quand même un peu fort c'est une
exclusivité de cette boutique c'est un
vinaigre à 7 degrés qui normalement est
destiné à la restauration aux
professionnels donc ça c'est un vinaigre
par exemple qu'on vend au ritz à paris
séduite ou conquise à intéresser surtout
c'est vrai que c'est un vinaigre qui
change par rapport à ce qu'on a
l'habitude qui peut en cuisine apporter
d'originalité
moi c'est ce que cherchent des choses un
peu originale puis locale orléans est
historiquement la capitale du vinaigre
et pour faire le parallèle avec un
produit que les français adorent et qui
est la bière on sait que la meilleure
des bières elle est servie à la pression
donc quand on souhaite faire le meilleur
des vinaigres et ben on le sert
également à la pression et c'est comme
ça qu'est née l'idée d'un buzz barras
binaire le discours est rodé à la
perfection patriotisme économique
produits made in france démarche éco
responsable
les clients sont séduits et repartent
les bras chargés de provisions